So let's talk about these
fights, bro. First of all,
let's start with Diego
motherfucking Sanchez.
All these young guns sleeping on
Diego Sanchez fully redeemed himself.
Do not sleep. Do not. Just do not,
just don't cause he will
fuck. Ugh. People up still.
How about Micky Gall bid and
do you see that? I saw this.
There's a video of him bite him.
Well there's a video of Diego going
look at this shit. Yeah, Diego.
I saw on his Instagram he showed his chest
where he takes a bit that it's crazy.
I thought they said Micky
Gall had a hard cut,
like a really hard cut and maybe that's
one of the reasons he got so tired.
I just don't think that so far he's just,
the skills aren't there yet.
Now he was out of his element a little
bit. Wow. I gave outclassed him.
Diego is a monster.
I mean you're dealing with a guy who
has 40 look at that bite mark. That is,
that is Cree bite the fuck Micky gall.
I'll buy bytes.
Guys had bitten guys before. Can't be
on my team. Yeah, you're off the team.
It's not good. It's bad luck. Me or
Diego didn't say shit to the referee.
Just kept smashed.
Dude.
He is such a savage and he's a sandwiches
fighting since he was four years old
in the Usda.
He won ultimate fighter season one,
2005 14 fucking years ago.
That mental weight. Yup.
14 fucking years ago.
You want to stop and think about what an
insane career that is and his last two
fights. Um, well I think you last
fight was Craig white does that,
who he fought last smashed that dude
smashed and then smashed Micky gall dude.
He, he's the, uh, he's the mascot for
Jackson's. Right? Like if there's a logo,
it's Diego Sanchez.
Yeah. And every prayer,
but he knows that is Brendan chops voice.
I sound like Alec Jones Right now.
Not here. Not Loud enough.
Yeah, you're right.
You sound like Brendan Chubb with a cold
that I don't see. I don't feel sick.
You don't feel stuck. So it's
just a sore throat I think. Yeah.
But how's your throat just go? We
screaming at someone. No, dubs chilling.
I did do podcasting for this Wolf House.
Sometimes my voice goes, I'm not sick.
Oh, that's so great. That's weird.
Cause I am sick a little
bit really around.
Well I had it over the weekend and
yesterday I felt like dog shit.
Do you work out? I worked
out, uh, not yesterday,
but Saturday I worked outside of it.
Probably wasn't a good idea.
They say when you work out,
when you're sick,
inmates at worst [inaudible] system's
down. I usually show up. Do it too.
I lifted too. And you know,
it's not smart. No, but I,
I'm okay today I'm just like
a little, little worn out,
but my voice is all right.
You just need some rest. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean I'll be fine. I'm traveling.
Doesn't help.
No,
it's the worst man because always I
always take the first flight back cause I
want to see my family and yeah, I
got the that makes it worse. Yeah.
I was up at five.
Um,
so Micky gall in that fight,
he asked for that fight.
That was a fight.
He was begging Dana white to give him.
He thought it was a good fight for him.
He thought it was a good match up.
I don't know why people think that,
I guess cause like she's been knocked out.
Right. Ally Quinta, k
Odom. Um, uh, Matt Brown,
Kod Dem. But he's a big name
has been doing for a long time.
So these young guys go, oh, I grew up
watching him. Let me get him. Well they,
I think they also think he's been doing
it for so long and they're right. Yeah.
But he still so fucking tough man.
He has all the skills.
He still has all the skills and his
ground and pound his fucking ferocious.
And once he's on the
ground then he doesn't,
I mean if there's a hole in Diego's game,
you would have to say against like
elite Strykers he has a real problem.
Like guys like Matt Brown,
he's going to have problems.
He's just not as fluid as
those guys, you know? Yeah.
Diego's grappling to
amazing, amazing, amazing.
And his ferocity cannot be questioned.
He's just mental games. Savage.
Just to think about the enthusiasm Diego
has after all these years in the game,
all these years in the game. Unbelievable.
Crazy. How many years? How many years?
What we know? Well, 14 years in the UFC,
but he fought before that he was,
he was a veteran.
He had several fights before
the yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. Crazy. Crazy. How long
he's been doing it and again,
how long he's been doing it and how much
he loves it still and he says CBD is
really helping him. He's got his
own CBD. 2002 damn motherfuckers.
17 years in years.
He fought Michael Johnson.
2000 same Michael Johnson.
No Way. Like my mine.
Michael was six years.
What's that?
His name would probably be tagged
there for it was? Yeah. Would right.
That's not Michael. Wow. He fought
Shannon rich on this third fight.
Shannon rich has like a million
fights cook on Shannon Rich,
which in my get Gaiman, the joker old
school to then click on Shannon. Rich,
how many fights is here? I'm going to
say he's got, how many does it say?
Holy Shit.
Say the regular houses.
53 it's Jesus Christ. It's the worst
record of everything. That's crazy.
That is crazy. Shout out to that guy
though. For keeping with it. You know,
that is Chris lost 79 times.
Jesus Christ, 42 kickboxing.
Oh my God. And 42 kickboxing
matches. Jesus Christ,
they kickbox and he's kind of
killing it. 35 and seven. Not Bad,
but that's an insane amount of experience.
But just stop and think about 17 years
in Diego's still slinging and so much
enthusiasm. That's a crazy part. It's not
just that he's fighting that he fights.
He was fucking angry cause
he had his own CBD company.
Now it gave me some of it any good.
I haven't tried it yet. He just gave,
he gave me some bottles of his stuff, but
he's human. He really believes in CBD.
A lot of fighters do. It's helping
them. Yeah. It's amazing. It's amazing.
Stops spectrum CBD. That's what I, yeah, I
mean, there's so many good companies now,
but uh.